[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen in Argentinien ist die
Hölle los mehr dazu von Norbert Lehmann
im Sport
und wir zeigen Ihnen unter anderem wie
Tiere und Pflanzen besser geschützt
werden sollen
Atemschutz für den Planeten der Welt
naturgipfel will bis 2030 an Land und im
Wasser 30% der Fläche unter
schutzstellen
Panzer Pleite Puma
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
bestellt keine neuen bevor klar ist
warum die alten ausgefallen sind
und kippelig in die Weihnachtswoche das
Glatteis macht allen zu schaffen die
heute unterwegs sind
das neue Artenschutzabkommen steht nach
knapp zweiwöchigen Verhandlungen beim
weltnaturgipfel in Montreal als
wegweisend lobte
un-generalsekretärisch die Einigung
Umweltschutzorganisationen geht sie
dagegen nicht weit genug das Herzstück
des Abkommens ist dieses Ziel bis 2030
wollen die Staaten mindestens 30% der
Landfläche und 30 Prozent der Meere
unter schutzstellen
unklar bleibt aber wie streng dieser
Schutz sein soll außerdem einigte sich
die Konferenz auf mehr Geld für den
Natur und Artenschutz reiche Länder
sollen ärmere dabei unterstützen bis
2025 mit 20 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr
weitere Details von Andreas Kühnast
es gibt nur eine Art die das
Artensterben stoppen kann der Mensch der
es nicht an Wissen mangelt aber an
Willen an Handeln an Geld in Montreal
haben 5000 Menschen verhandelt wie die
vielfältigen Leben auf diesem Planeten
zu retten sind auch die der eigenen Art
weil die Krise des Arten Aussterbens der
Zerstörung unserer Naturschätze
inzwischen so weit vorangeschritten ist
dass es uns selber als Menschheit
bedroht als in dieser Nacht als um 3:33
Uhr endlich der hammerfeld bricht Jubel
aus gemessen an den schwierigen
Verhandlungen bringt die Konferenz ein
überraschend gutes Ergebnis viel mehr
Schutzgebiete etwa doppelt so viele wie
bisher viel weniger Pestizide und
gefährliche Chemikalien und viel weniger
umweltschädliche Subventionen von den
geschätzt 8 Millionen Tier und
Pflanzenarten sind eine Million vom
Aussterben bedroht darunter 10% aller
Insekten
in Montreal verpflichten sich die
reichenländer wie Deutschland die
besonders viel Natur verbraucht haben
den armen Ländern zu helfen von denen
viele noch besonders viel Natur haben
Umwelt und Tierschutzorganisationen
bleiben skeptisch man muss hier klar
sagen dass die Massenvernichtungswaffe
Mensch hier auf dieser Welt
naturkonferenz nur bedingt entschärft
wurde die Finanzierungslücke die ist
riesig um den um die Natur zu schützen
es gibt nur eine Art die das Arten
sterben stoppen kann in Montreal bringt
die Menschheit den nötigen Willen auf
aber noch nicht die nötigen Mittel
und Andreas Kühnast ist uns jetzt aus
Montreal zugeschaltet Andreas welche
Bedeutung hat dieses Abkommen
es ist schon ein beachtlicher Schritt
vor allem das Ziel 30 Prozent dieses
Planeten unter Schutz zu stellen wird
von nun an für immer der Maßstab von
Montreal sein an dem ein Gelingen
genauso gemessen werden wird wie ein
Scheitern und dass das zustande gekommen
ist das muss man so sagen liegt auch zu
einem Großteil an Deutschland dass ihr
vorangegangen ist dass hier auch
finanziell vorangegangen ist während
andere Länder während die USA zum
Beispiel überhaupt gar nicht hochrangig
vertreten waren und das ist jetzt
natürlich die große Gefahr für die
schöne Theorie von Montreal dieses
Artenschutzabkommen könnte in der Praxis
keinen Zwang es kennt keine Strafen und
so wird es eben allein auf guten Willen
setzen und guten Willen allein der hat
bei unserer Art nicht immer gereicht
jetzt geht es also um die Umsetzung
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung
Andreas
nachdem der Schützenpanzer Puma wegen
technischer Probleme bei
bundeswehrübungen ausgefallen ist gab es
heute ein Krisengespräch im
Verteidigungsministerium woran die
Pannen liegen ist noch unklar aber klar
ist es werden jetzt erstmal keine neuen
Puma Panzer bestellt hieß es danach und
die Bundeswehr setzt für die schnelle
NATO Eingreiftruppe nun vorerst auf den
älteren Panzer Marder die Einzelheiten
von Christiane hübscher
18 Puma Panzer die nicht fahren nicht
funken und nicht schießen wie sie sollen
und eine Verteidigungsministerin die
heute sehr klar mit dem Finger auf die
Rüstungsindustrie zeigt wir brauchen
jetzt sehr schnell die Instandsetzung
der entsprechenden Pumas aber wir
brauchen darüber hinaus eine
verlässliche Perspektive wenn dieses mit
diesem System weiter geplant werden soll
Lambrecht die gerade für den Ringtausch
mit der Ukraine in der Slowakei ist
stoppt vorerst den Nachkauf von Puma
Schützenpanzern die Blamage für die
Verteidigungsministerin perfekt offenbar
ging ein Software Update schief vermuten
Militärexperten
und diese 18 also eine Kompanie sind
jetzt so mal einem gewissen Härtetest
unterzogen worden und eigentlich dachte
man dass dieser dieser elektronik-update
der Software Update funktionieren würde
soweit ich das weiß ist man im her auch
überrascht dass das jetzt dann diese
Probleme gab die kurzfristige Lösung
Deutschland schickt alte Marder
Schützenpanzer statt des Puma zur NATO
Eingreiftruppe ins Baltikum die Union
hat deshalb bereits eine konkrete
Befürchtung das darf nicht zu
Entschuldigung dienen dass wir die
Ukraine nicht weiter unterstützen im
Gegenteil das ist ein Weckruf und die
deutsche Industrie ist hier in der
pflichtbewusst dass sehr rasch aufklären
und auf die Verteidigungsministerin
steigt zu Hause der Druck wenn man
Milliarden ausgibt und dann letztlich 6
Milliarden Schrott erhält dann muss die
Verteidigungsministerin die Frage des
Regresses stellen die NATO können sich
zu 100% auf Deutschlands Zusagen
verlassen versichert Christine Lambrecht
in Bratislava heute noch
nach monatelangen Ringen haben sich die
EU-Staaten auf einen gaspreisdeckel
geeinigt unter bestimmten Umständen soll
der Großhandelspreis für Gas dadurch bei
180€ Pro megabytestunde gedeckelt werden
das ganze solle ab Mitte Februar gelten
die Bundesregierung verlange gegen so
einen markteingriff über das Treffen der
eu-energieministerin und Minister
Florian neuhahn
sie waren längst in den Nachspielzeit
der Verlängerung 12 Sitzung der
Energieminister in diesem Jahr zum
Gaspreis Deckel den die einen unbedingt
einführen die anderen unbedingt
verhindern wollten und dann kann der
aktuelle EU-Ratsvorsitzende doch noch
verkünden
wir haben unsere Arbeit getan wir haben
einen Deal wir haben eine weitere
unmögliche Aufgabe gelöst
Europa will einen Höchstpreis festsetzen
den es für Gas an andere Staaten zahlt
und das nach einem Jahr in dem der
Gaspreis bisher unbekannte Höhen
erklommen die EU-Kommission hatte für
einen Deckel zunächst 275 €
vorgeschlagen Deckel Befürworter wollten
eher 100 € nun die Einigung auf 180 €
pro Megawattstunde Gas es ist ein
markteingriff den vor allem die deutsche
Bundesregierung stets abgelehnt hatte
aus Sorge dass die Tanker ihr Gas dann
woanders hin verkaufen doch am Ende
drohte der deutsche Wirtschaftsminister
überstimmt zu werden und lenkte ein
zähneknirschend aus meiner Skepsis kann
ich kein heel machen aber so wie die
anderen Länder solidarisch mit
Deutschland in der Vergangenheit waren
haben wir heute die Solidarität mit
diesem Instrument gezeigt ein ganzes
Netz an sicherheitspuffern soll nun
verhindern dass deutsche Befürchtungen
wahr werden sobald etwa ein
Mitgliedstaat an den Gas Mangel
feststellt wird der Deckel ausgesetzt
und sowieso soll er erst nach einer
Prüfphase gelten ab Mitte Februar
nächsten Jahres erst startet Europa
seine Operation gaspreisdeckel
in der Ukraine hat Russland wieder die
Hauptstadt Kiew und die Umland
attackiert mit mindestens 35 Drohnen
iranischer Bauart so krainische Angaben
die Angriffe vergangenen Nacht galten
erneut auch der Energieversorgung in
einigen Stadtteilen wurde der Strom
abgeschaltet um Kiew herum wurden durch
Kampfdrohnen Wohnhäuser zerstört und
zwei Zivilisten verletzt erst am Freitag
hatte Russland ukrainische Städte mit
Raketen angegriffen
steht in den USA bald einen früherer
Präsident vor Gericht ein
Untersuchungsausschuss des Kongresses
hat fast 18 Monate lang das Verhalten
von Donald Trump untersucht nun naht der
Abschlussbericht mit einer Empfehlung
für die Justiz im Mittelpunkt stehen die
Ereignisse vom 6 Januar 2021 damals
hatten Radikale trump-anhänger und
Anhängerinnen das Kapital gestürmt und
meine Bestätigung das war sie das von
Joe Biden zu verhindern Trump wird
vorgeworfen sie mit einer Rede dazu
angestachelt zu haben
und die Untersuchung beobachtet für uns
Elma teven Elmar worauf deutet es denn
hin was wird der Ausschuss empfehlen
also der Ausschuss der gerade mit seiner
Sitzung begonnen hat wird etwas tun was
es in der amerikanischen Geschichte noch
nie gegeben hat nämlich tatsächlich
formell das Justizministerium auffordern
Anklage zu erheben gegen einen
ehemaligen Präsidenten und einige seiner
Berater Donald Trump werden drei Punkte
vorgeworfen Anstiftung zum Aufruhr dann
der Versuch einen offiziellen Vorgang
hier im Kongress zu stoppen und damit
drittens eben das amerikanische Volk um
das Wahlergebnis zu betrügen nun hat
diese Weiterleitung der Fehler
eigentlich keine rechtlich bindende
Wirkung für das Justizministerium
deswegen hat Donald Trump das auch in
den letzten Tagen schon als Känguru
Gericht bezeichnen lassen aber es ist
trotzdem mehr als nur ein sehr starkes
Signal denn der Kongress hat über Monate
Beweismaterial gesammelt mehr als eine
Million Dokumente Aussagen von mehr als
1000 Zeugen wurden gehört und dieses
Material kann weitergegeben werden an
das Justizministerium das wäre
gewissermaßen eine Schatzkiste für die
Ermittler und auf dieser Grundlage
könnte man Anklage erheben am Ende kommt
es dann darauf an ob der Justizminister
politisch den Mut hat in dieser
aufgeladenen Stimmung im Land und auch
angesichts eines beginnenden Wahlkampfes
für die Präsidentschaftswahl 2024
wirklich auch Anklage gegen Donald Trump
zu erheben danke für diese Einordnung
kaum ein Tag ohne eine neue wollte von
Elon Musk bei Twitter jetzt hat der
US-Milliardär die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer
abstimmen lassen ob er als Twitter Chef
abtreten soll oder nicht und promstücken
57,5% für seinen Rücktritt verkündet hat
er den aber bisher nicht
für viele Menschen in Deutschland stellt
sich heute eine Frage muss ich wirklich
raus oder kann ich vielleicht doch zu
Hause bleiben denn jeder Meter draußen
wird zum Balanceakt auf Eis gelten
starten Wegen und Straßen ab danach zog
ein regengebet von Westen her über fast
ganz Deutschland und traf auf
tiefgefrorenen Boden der Osten hat auch
heute Abend noch damit zu tun Julia
Schröter
thorstende Schrittchen und immer gut
festhalten denn es ist so schnell
passiert so wie ihm mag es heute so
manchem ergangen sein
spiegelglatt also es ist wirklich
manchmal eine größere Rutschpartie als
dass man laufen kann wer konnte blieb am
besten gleich zu Hause
auf den Straßen versuchten die
Winterdienste so gut es ging gegen die
Glätte anzustreuen und konnten trotzdem
hunderte Unfälle nicht verhindern auf
der A27 bei Walsrode in Niedersachsen
durchbrach der Fahrer dieses Wagens die
Leitplanke und prallte gegen einen Baum
der 25-Jährige starb wer aus
Sicherheitsgründen auf die Bahn Umstieg
brauchte Geduld wie hier in Hamburg denn
Züge durften wegen des Eises zeitweise
nur mit reduziertem Tempo fahren ich
hoffe dass die Verspätung sich nicht
noch weiter ausdehnt weil ich die Fähre
kriegen muss nach Oslo weil so viele
Menschen auf dem Eis ausrutschen ist in
Hamburg eine Turnhalle für die
Versorgung von Verletzten eingerichtet
worden es wird vorsortiert wer am
dringendsten behandelt werden muss damit
nicht alle Patienten auf einmal in die
überlasteten Notaufnahmen strömen
dass es gleichzeitig flächendeckend in
ganz Deutschland diesen tiefgefrorenen
Boden gab und ein so massives tief von
Westen herankam das ist durchaus
ungewöhnlich so viele glatteis-meldungen
zeitgleich in Deutschland habe ich
wirklich ganz selten gesehen Deutschland
schlittert in die Weihnachtswoche die
gute Nachricht am Abend ist das Glatteis
überall durch
klar da ist Opfer mit Knochenbrüchen
dürften die Situation in den Kliniken
also noch verschärft haben dort ist das
Personal sowieso knapp unter Zeit sei
etwa jeder zehnte Beschäftigte selbst
krank mit Infektionskrankheiten wie im
Grippe oder Corona melden die Kliniken
außerdem gibt es ja noch das RS Virus
das vor allem junge Menschen trifft auf
den Kinderstation ist die Lage daher
besonders kritisch einer Hebestreit
berichtet aus Lübeck für die kleine
hanna ist es ein rumpeliger Staat ins
Leben gerade sechs Wochen alt liegt sie
in Lübeck auf der Kinder Intensivstation
sie hat sich infiziert mit dem RS Virus
ohne Hilfe bekommt sie nicht genügend
Sauerstoff
natürlich unter Gegenwehr dann irgendwie
angekabelt wird und
beatmet wird ist das natürlich schon
auch mit vielen Tränen verbunden und
auch so ein bisschen Verzweiflung die
Uniklinik in Lübeck ist schon zu 98
Prozent ausgelastet das Virus sorgt aber
weiter auch für schwere
Krankheitssymptome hohes Fieber über
längere Zeit wenn die Kinder eine
auffällige Atmung haben wenn sie nicht
richtig trinken
dann sollte man auf jeden Fall den den
Kinderarzt eben aufsuchen und sich davon
auch nicht abschrecken lassen dass man
jetzt eben warten muss warten auch weil
die Helfer am Anschlag sind viele Fallen
selbst erkrankt aus dazu sind offene
Stellen in der Kinderpflege kaum zu
besetzen auch so sagen sie hier weil der
Bundestag das Pflegegesetz so geändert
habe dass es keine reine
kinderpflegeausbildung mehr gibt und wir
sehen jetzt leider das Produkt davon und
man kann eigentlich nur an die Politik
noch mal die Aufforderung dann macht
wieder eine extra
kinderpflegeausbildung damit wir auch
genügend Nachwuchs bekommen auch wenn
Hannah wohl ihr erstes Weihnachten im
Krankenhaus verbringen muss die
Heilungschancen für Patienten mit dem
RS-Virus gelten als gut
Gesundheit im Notbetrieb so lautet der
Titel eines viso-spezials um 19 Uhr
rund 90 Jahre ist es her dass eine
Rabbinerfamilie vor dem Nazi-Regime Flo
die Nachfahren der postenas besuchten
nun Deutschland und feiert mit
Bundespräsident Steinmeier das
Lichterfest Hanukkah im Schloss Bellevue
entzündete ein Enkel je rudermannsbach
den Leuchter den die familiens heutige
Israel mitgenommen hatte
Steinmeier nannte ist ein Geschenk das
in Deutschland wieder jüdisches Leben
blüht
[Musik]
ein Elfer und nanzeck vor rund 24
Stunden beförderte dieser Schuss
Argentinien ins Glück die Mannschaft
rund um superstar Lionel Messi ist
Fußballweltmeister der erste aus
Südamerika seit 20 Jahren der Erfolg
gibt dem Land nicht nur sportlich
Aufwind zumindest für eine Weile sind
die Symptome der heftigen Krise des
Landes in den Hintergrund getreten etwa
die Inflationsrate von gut 70 Prozent in
diesem Jahr Christoph röckerath ist für
uns in Buenos Aires
selbst für die Feuerwehr gibt es kein
Entkommen Minuten nach dem Ende des
Spiels stürmen die Fans alles was ich
ihnen in den Weg stellt am Ende sind es
rund eine Million Menschen die ins
Zentrum von Buenos Aires strömen
argentinien ist Weltmeister
es ist der schönste Tag meines Lebens
toll dass meine Kinder dabei sind
ein Tag an dem sie sich noch lange
erinnern werden auch weil das Spiel an
Dramatik nicht zu überbieten ist mit
später Erlösung
Argentinien dürfte den Gewinn der
Weltmeisterschaft herbei gesehen haben
die kaum ein anderes Land die von
wirtschaftlicher Dauerkrise und
politischer Spaltung gebeutelten
Argentinier erleben ein gemeinsamen
Moment des Glücks nach langer Zeit und
auch wenn der nicht von Dauer sein mag
zu hoffen doch viele dass dies neuen
Schwung gibt für das Land und seine
Menschen bis in die Nacht feiern Sie
rund um den Obelisken im Zentrum am Tag
danach kehrt erst einmal Ruhe ein die
Euphorie aber bleibt und spendet Trost
in Zeiten der Krise ich kann es immer
noch nicht fassen es ist eine
unglaubliche Freude für alle Argentinier
ist für uns wie ein Familienmitglied
oder ein enger Freund bei allen Fehlern
verbindet uns trotzdem eine
bedingungslose Liebe
[Musik]
und nach der Feier ist vor der Feier
morgen wollen Sie hier Ihre WM-Helden
empfangen dann dürften noch einmal
zehntausende am Obelisken ihr Glück in
den Himmel schreien
Argentinien feiert also über Tage den
WM-Titel und wir haben es ja gerade
gesehen vor allem einen Mann Lionel
Messe endlich hat er es geschafft und
steht jetzt im argentinischen Fußball
Olymp auf einer Stufe mit Diego Maradona
Weltfußballer war er schon oft
Weltmeister aber noch nicht die Krönung
einer einzigartigen Karriere
Lionel Messi der vollendete schießt
Argentinien mit insgesamt sieben
Treffern zum WM-Titel es ist der 35
Titel seiner Karriere und als
Weltmeister ist der für viele jetzt der
Fußball Messias
ich freue mich so ich bin glücklich für
mich für mein Team und für ganz
Argentinien
die Welt jubelt und diskutiert über das
traditionelle Gewand aus Katha das Messi
im stolzesten Moment seiner Karriere
ungehängt wird und das Nationaltrikot
überdeckt im gesamten Turnier
beeindruckte er mit seiner ganz eigenen
Brillanz langem Schatten von Diego
Maradona dem großen Vorbild jetzt eben
würdig Pelé schrieb Glückwunsch Diego
lächelt jetzt Barack Obama nennt die
Gott greatest of all time 17 Jahre hat
er auf dieses Ziel hingearbeitet nun ist
er angekommen
von einem Sportler des Jahrhunderts zu
unseren Sportlern des Jahres gestern
Abend in Baden-Baden die große zdf-gala
2 Leichtathletik Asse und ein
Fußball-Bundesligist sind die Gewinner
die Gesichter der European Championships
in München sind auch die Sportlerin und
der Sportler des Jahres Niklas Kaul und
Gina lückenkemper
irgendwann mal mein Enkelkindern ja
erklären möchte dann werde ich definitiv
auf ganz viele Videomaterial
zurückgreifen für mich war es wahnsinnig
emotional und anscheinend also der
Wettkampf anscheinend für die
Sportjournalisten auch Mannschaft des
Jahres Eintracht Frankfurt doch vor der
Fußball Frauen Nationalmannschaft aber
mit nur einem einzigen Gast Präsident
Peter Fischer total verrückt niemals
erwartet dazu die Liebeserklärung von
Laudator und Eintracht wenn Sebastian
Vettel im Herzen von Europa liegt mein
Frankfurt am Main dort gibt es eine
Eintracht die spielt Fußball ganz famos
mit ihr wurde ich und so viele Menschen
groß
[Applaus]
starker Auftritt von Alexander Schmidt
beim Weltcup Riesenslalom in
italienischen Alter Badia dank eines
starken finallaufs verbesserte sich der
Allgäuer noch um vom 7 auf den fünften
Rang seinen bislang bestes Saison
Resultat
und Sieger wieder mal der Schweizer
Marco oder matt das war's danke schön
von Westen ist es jetzt viel milder
geworden ob wir dadurch von Glätte Forst
verschont bleiben erfahren Sie gleich
von Katja horneffer das heute schon mal
läuft um 21:45 Uhr mit mariaslonka und
hier geht's jetzt weiter mit einem
Spezial zur Lage in der Ukraine bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend der gefährliche Glatteis
regenwälzte sich heute von
Nordrhein-Westfalen starbend weiter nach
Osten und erreichte bis zum Abend auch
Ostsachsen und Vorpommern damit ist aber
die Frostluft im Wesentlichen aus
Deutschland weggeräumt und so liegen die
Tiefsttemperaturen hier im Westen bei
recht milden 7 bis 2 Grad Frost gibt's
eigentlich nur noch in Bayern da gehen
die Temperaturen auf -3 bis -6 Grad
zurück dort bleibt es glücklicherweise
trocken etwas glatt als Regen kann es am
Anfang der Nacht hier noch in Vorpommern
geben und auch in den Mittelgebirgen ist
es zum Teil noch rutschig im Nordwesten
fällt nämlich Regen bei Südwestwind und
diese Wetter Zweiteilung haben wir auch
morgen über Tag hier im nordwestenfeld
häufig Regen bei Südwestwind Richtung
Südosten ist das dagegen meist trocken
und ab und zu zeigt sich die Sonne auch
häufiger besonders wohl am alten Rand
und nur in Niederbayern hält sich morgen
noch ein bisschen was von der Frost Luft
sonst wird zum Teil schon richtig mild
frühlingshaft fast am oberrheinsteigen
die Werte bis 12 Grad und auch in den
nächsten Tagen geht es regnerisch und
recht mild weiter am Freitag steigen die
Temperaturen bis 16 Grad und dann droht
Sturm guten Abend